foreign
Marty's with us in Waco hi Marty welcome
to the Ramsey Show
young man I'm glad I could get a hold of
you
you too glad you're here brother how can
we help
uh yes so I started listening uh
Thanksgiving uh last week and
um I'm essentially starting my baby step
Journey uh last two years I've kind of
restarted my life uh twice
and
um uh I might
have a son that to be determined
hopefully by the end of the week
um so I'm just trying to you know
finally get my head straight and uh I
mean I've been thinking about this
season before
um trying to establish a paternity
anyways get my head straight and I've
been making strides over the last few
years
um in my life and I just Financial
stability is a big thing that I still
need to work on though
when you say you've restarted your life
twice over the last couple years what
does that mean
uh yeah so
um
I guess uh the long short story is uh
I've been on my own since I was 12 went
to the Marines and I did a seven years
but as soon as I got in the Marines I
essentially went back to just being as
Frugal and humble as I was before
because uh you know didn't really have
any major skill any formal formally
trained skills I could put on resumes
and everything
um but I finally found a job who's
willing to get uh that was willing to
give me a chance and I've proven myself
um and then uh
through that I thought I
um found uh so sorry
um whenever I came to this job I left my
hometown in San Antonio okay
um was living on the side of the road
for a month so I finally got money to
you know get a place
and then I heard of a job opportunity
that was supposed that did pay more back
home went back home but the cost of
living hit me again and uh went there
for my savings at San Antonio that's
Antonio okay so then uh you've woke up
and found yourself where are you living
right now
uh here um near Waco I'm about 45
minutes from Waco okay and you got a
good job
yes all right what do you mean I work
for the state so okay what do you make
31 000. okay and how old are you
26. okay so you're not homeless
you're stable you got a sustainable
situation
and it sounds like you got a girl
pregnant
uh yes okay and you're waiting to hear
about the uh paternity of the baby which
she is carrying correct or has been born
a year and a half old now
Okay so
uh uh and you're just hearing about this
why
uh I'm not just hearing about this uh
whenever we found out she's pregnant
um soon after she broke up with me and
uh she avoided all my attempts to reach
her so I could you know attempt to be
the father that
um I wanted to be
um and uh yesterday after church
um I decided
um I went by memory where her dad was
luckily I was able to find a place and I
was able to get back in touch with her
and she was finally willing to
compromise so yesterday we talked like
hey I want to order a home paternity
test and uh
um which I I'm gonna order today okay
I'm gonna step in and call bullcrap on
some of this okay
you have a legal right to your kid
and I want whether she tries to block or
not I want there to be a record so that
we already have no no no no I want there
to be a track record let me say that way
so that one day when you sit down eye to
eye chest to chest with this young son
I want you to be able to say I fought
for you I went to the ends of the Earth
for you I worked four jobs do what
I have a manila envelope of proving all
the texts and um
now listen listen whether this paternity
test proves true at the end of this week
or not
you're you've been going halfway
okay and it's time to fully step into
who you are gonna be
is that fair
yes of course and uh thankfully uh I've
uh we found a religion uh recently and
that's like I said I've been making
major strides in my life the last few
years
um you know becoming a better man good
so good good good it sounds like you got
a lot of things heading in a positive
direction after
um a lot of circuit a lot of circling
the wagons back and forth back and forth
back and forth so yeah no good good for
you I'm glad for you yeah I'm proud for
you good good move yeah so so run this
to ground find out with a paternity test
whether this is yours if it is yours
you're all in as a new dad like you said
and like John said you're gonna make a
record you're going to insert yourself
into the life of the child and uh you're
you've got to insert yourself into the
life of this church so you've got some
good men walking along beside you and
that can teach you things that
you've been looking for since you were
12. you found a few of them in the
Marines you'll find the rest of them in
the church
and um which are skills on how to be a
man
and uh you're learning that and there's
no harm there's no shame in the fact
that you're learning that uh now uh the
only shame will be is if you don't
bother to play through and to learn it
and we'll help you with the money piece
of it uh if you'll hang on I'm gonna
have the guys pick up and we're going to
sign you up for the best thing we have
which is Financial Peace University it's
nine weeks long and you can take the
lessons on how to handle money like a
grown-up uh like a boss and uh how to
not only get out of debt not only how to
live on what you make and start to
address your career issues with Ken
Coleman stuff if you want to as well
um I mean if you'll come around all the
Ramsey stuff we'll walk with you in all
these different areas of your life yeah
I'll give you a copy of own your pass
change your future as well yeah I want
you to read that book all the way
through we'll send you a a an audio link
too so if you're if you're not a reader
you can listen to it while you're
driving yeah because really there's a so
much to that idea right there in your
situation it is in everybody's life but
owning your past say this is what
happened
but it does not dictate my future that's
right and change your future so John's
book will be in the mix as well that we
give you we're going to load you up with
homework buddy it's all free
um the only problem is now you got to go
do all the work
and we're here to help you call anytime
any of us will help you here with any
part of this but you're all in now it's
all looking forward going forward no
more circling
straight lines
lots of straight lines
and I lean into the guys at that church
make them lean into your life and let
them speak into you